welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and spider-man has returned to the
MCU with Disney and Sony finally
agreeing on a deal that would allow at
least two more movies with Tom Hollands
spider-man as part of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and Marvel head Kevin
Feige back co-producing the upcoming
third spider-man movie which now has
just got to be titled spider-man back
home welcome home home again no place
like home home sweet home or justice
should be spider-man insert this clip
anyway I'm gonna break down what this
new deal is the insane story behind how
it came together and what it means for
every future spider-man film appearance
of course these next two and beyond
because this apparent victory is really
just one move in a long game plan that
even Nick Fury would have trouble seeing
through so here it is the new spider-man
MCU deal explained ok recently Marvel
head Kevin Feige Sony exec Tom Rothman
and Disney execs Alan horn and Alan
Bergman sat down to work out a plan to
extend the deal for the studio's to
co-produced spider-man as they've been
doing since 2015 my guy helps produce
Sony Tom Hollands spider-man movies in
the MCU for a small cut of the profit
and gets the feature that same
spider-man and his own MCU team-up
movies
talks to extend this partnership past
far from home broke down last month over
Disney wanting to increase their profit
share from 5 percent to 50 percent and
Sony said no so he actually hinted that
Feige was too busy for spider-man which
we now might be able to interpret as a
veiled nod at the big new Star Wars
project that IV has in the works but now
a new deal has been signed for at least
two more films first a third spider-man
film a follow up too far from home with
Tom Holland produced by Feige in which
Disney Co finances and profits 25% this
movie will come out on July 16th 2021
and second a future TBD film in Disney's
Marvel lineup in which spider-man can
appear as he did in civil war infinity
war and in Guara remain presumably this
film will come out sometime in 2022
maybe 2023 but more on that in a bit let
us start with spider-man 3 coming July
2021 plugging this into Marvel's phase 4
lineup this film will come two months
after Doctor Strange in the multiverse
of madness coming May 2021 and four
months before Thor love and thunder
coming November 2021 with Shane xi in
the legend of the ten rings coming
February 22 one that means we're gonna
have four MCU films in 2021
nice bounce back from only having two in
2020 and that's gonna be on top of or
new Marvel series streaming on Disney
Plus in 2021 Wan Division Loki
what if and Hawkeye be far from home
screenwriters Chris McKenna and Eric
summers began drafting the third movie
script last summer
and these negotiations haven't
necessarily changed the core narrative
of that film MCU were no MCU the third
film was all
almost certainly going to deal with the
ramifications of Peter Parker being
publicly outed by day jonah Jameson's
Daily Bugle and we've speculated that he
could now face Spidey villains like
these sinister six Norman Osborn Kraven
the hunter and or a crossover with venom
and carnage but now that this deal has
been reached Peter can continue to face
these challenges in a world populated by
the other Avengers in addition to Doctor
Strange black panther Nick Fury and
really the whole legacy of Tony Stark
like spider-man can still use a stark
tech of the iron spider armor he never
has to avoid swinging past Avengers
tower and Aunt May doesn't have to break
up with happy Hogan anymore I see that
has an absolute win this also keeps the
door open to go deeper into the
conspiracy surrounding Mysterio and his
team of former stark engineers like many
of you we continue to question the
circumstances around Quentin Beck's
death and we don't even know if Quentin
Beck was his name and now all characters
like William Gynt arriva who as a stark
employee was more of an MCU figure can
continue to play a role in spider-man's
a narrative that also goes for the
double twist in the second far from home
post credits scene Nick Fury's
partnership with the shape-shifting
scrolls this now gives Peter another
tactic to try to help clear his name
simply a released footage of a scroll
shape-shifting into Peter Parker
spider-man and blame it all on the
squirrel yeah try to do something with
that Jameson actually he would love to
do something with that but it's the
second film that presents the most
possibilities because this gives us a
look furthest into the MCU future the
next major tentpole crossover event
Doctor Strange the multiverse of madness
authorial of inventor look real exciting
but this isn't the big tamale or big
tamales the thing is it hot tamale
whatever there's there's some kind of
MCU delicious Mexican food that's out
there and we don't know about and we've
yet to see if Marvel will continue with
Avengers films this would be the fifth
or if the Avengers title was specific to
Marvel's infinity saga and they got
different kind of crossover events
planned for the future like an alternate
team of option could be the Fantastic
Four spider-man has historically had
close connections with Johnny Storm Reed
Richards Sue Storm and Ben Grimm
throughout the comics history Marvel's
first family more than any of the other
Fox properties that Marvel reacquired
are beyond ready for a reboot and
introducing the Fantastic Four would
allow Feige to also introduce the Silver
Surfer and Galactus eater of worlds as
the new big bad a character he has
hinted at before in interviews
Kamio little practice cameo in there
and spider-mans MC appearances have
featured a few possible Easter eggs
referencing these Fantastic Four plans
if they exist far from home ended with
Peter and MJ in front of a sign reading
we are so excited to show you what comes
next one two three then question mark
and this was after Peter glided through
a newly constructed atrium in the old
Avengers tower suggesting new occupants
possibly the Fantastic Four turning the
tower into the new Baxter building also
one of the final shots of spider-man
homecoming showed Peter in Avengers HQ
watching a jet take off and we have no
idea who that was and Peter was framed
perfectly in front of the a logo to make
that a look almost like a four but
another possible team-up for spider-man
and MCU could be with the mutants one
rumor during these negotiations
suggested there might have been some
plans to show Peter in college teaming
up with Iceman and Firestar like the
eighties animated series spider-man and
his amazing friends now Iceman and
Firestar are mutants in the Marvel
comics and they could be away in the MCU
to introduce an even larger community of
mutants Marvel could also consider
moving in a more grounded direction for
its future storylines in which case
spider-man could team up would blade
whom we know we'll have a reboot
starring Marshall Elise sometime in
Marvel's future
similarly spider-man could team up with
a rebooted Matt Murdock daredevil now
that the Netflix series is finished with
Peter Parker now being labeled a
murderer he really could use the best
defense attorney in New York and while
we're on that subject Jennifer Walters
in the upcoming she-hulk series could be
a great inclusion on this legal dream
team now as I said this latest disney
sony deal is for only two movies for now
they may renegotiate and extend the deal
beyond that or Marvel may be using these
two movies to wind down this Peter
Parker's arc in the MCU in a way that
provides closure in his statement bagi
said that spider-man is quote the only
superhero with the super-powered across
cinematic universes so as Sony continues
to develop their own Spidey verse you
never know what surprises the future
might hold that is a pretty cryptic and
seemingly generous statement that allows
for a hypothetical future in which
Spiderman lives on in the universe
outside the MCU that could imply some
plan using the rules the MCU is
established with parallel timelines
within the multiverse to trans
and Peter Parker out of this reality
maybe starting with the events of dr.
strange in the multiverse of madness
perhaps pikeys offer to Sony was look
let's close out this six chapters story
arc of Tom Holland Peter Parker properly
in the cinematic universe he belongs in
then once we say goodbye to him you Sony
can start fresh in your own Sony
spider-verse with a live action Miles
Morales or Gwen Stacy or Miguel Herrera
and maybe an older mentor version of
Peter that no fan will complain if you
recast by that point Becky will have had
two more whole movies with Peter Parker
to introduce a new voice in the MCU to
carry that torch of youthful
wisecracking
which fulfillment like Richard Ryder
Nova Bobby Drake Ice Man Johnny Storm
Human Torch all the sounds pretty nice
and kumbaya but here's the true deal
folks by who knows what surprises could
come up by guys really saying I want
blood because by the time this deal ends
in 2022 or 2023 the world that we know
will have changed in at least two key
ways first Tom Holland who has two
spider-man movies left on his contract
with Sony will probably be ready to move
on to acting roles that don't require
him to worry about spoiling everything
in an interview and then Sony forced to
shift gears yet again will have even
less leverage than they do now and to
three to four years of skyrocketing
profits from its film releases streaming
service theme park attractions in
merchandise scene including all of the
profits from spider-man merch will make
Disney profitable enough to make Sony an
offer they can't refuse and buy out
Sony's film and TV properties just like
they did with Fox now I know that's a
lot of money and it seems a bit unlikely
but I would say it was way less likely
for a media mogul like Rupert Murdoch to
ever sell any piece of his box to Empire
and that happened everyone's got a
number
Feige wants his spider-man and now with
20% more of the profits of the
spider-man movies he's gonna help Sony
make he has positioned Disney even
closer to being able to drown Sony and
cash in three or four years buy back
spider-man and reunite the whole Marvel
family under one film studio and within
one cinematic universe so while this
whole scare might have just been staged
and the plan was always to extend the
deal the play wasn't on us it was on
Sony and every rival film studio who has
something Disney once and we were just
part of the outrage machine that helped
force so need accident
being a sheep never felt so great
spider-man is back but hey that's just
my explanation but shifting to less
cynical things what team up and see you
event do you want to see spider-man in
comment down below with your thoughts on
all this follow me on instagram and
twitter at a boss and subscribe to new
rockstars to get all your marvel
mysteries explained thank you for
joining me and while tom holland had a
perfect Instagram post to sum up his
feelings it was by far Jeff Goldblum who
had the best take a whole friggin month
ago looking like spider-man may go back
to Sony and not be part of the MCU
anymore I don't know it'll all work out
I'm sure hey good luck I'll figure it
out he's so weird
[Music]